este centro de vacunación cerca de parís
opera a toda máquina
tres mil personas vienen aquí cada día
para recibir su inyección el anuncio es
un empujón no estar vacunado cierra
muchas puertas
es bueno aplicarse la primera inyección
ahora estamos de vacaciones en agosto
con mi pareja y nuestras vacaciones se
arruinarán si ella puede ir a un
restaurante porque está vacunada y yo no
supe a fondeados inicialmente el centro
de vacunación planeaba cerrar sus
puertas en agosto pero ahora permanecerá
abierto y está pidiendo dosis
adicionales para atender el aumento de
la demanda solíamos tener alrededor de
30 personas por día que se presentaban
sin una cita ahora estamos en alrededor
de 300 pero francia es el país más
escéptico de las vacunas en el mundo y
aunque la vacuna es la herramienta más
eficaz que tiene para prevenir una
cuarta ola de infecciones algunos siguen
dudando después de una fecha determinada
la vacunación se vuelve obligatoria te
obligan a hacer los más de un millón de
personas en francia pidieron cita para
vacunas en menos de un día después del
discurso del presidente los jóvenes
constituyen la mayor parte de los
solicitantes unimos diseñamos 20.000
espacios
por minuto en el pico la demanda seguirá
siendo alta durante los próximos días
porque los centros de vacunas están
poniendo constantemente nuevos espacios
disponibles una manera más de aumentar
la presión sobre los anti vacunas el
gobierno ya no pagará las pruebas de
kobe sin receta médica ya que la
prevención es la mejor cura